CHOICE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
HE IS LOOKING TO WIN FACT
DISILLUSIONED YOUNG VOTERS FOR
FOR THE MIDTERMS SOME LAWMAKERS
ARE CALLING A BRIBE.
REPORT SUGGESTS HIS
ADMINISTRATION IS MULLING A PLAN
TO PAUSE STUDENT LOAN REPAYMENTS
AND GIVE $10,000 IN DEBT.
THERE IS GROWING EVIDENCE THAT
AMERICANS ARE STARTING TO
QUESTION IF COLLEGE IS EVEN
WORTH THE COST.
ONLY 55% OF PEOPLE SAY GETTING A
DEGREE HAS HAD A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON THE COUNTRY AND THAT IS DOWN
14 POINTS FROM 2020.
I DON'T KNOW, DANA, IS THERE A
MAJOR INFLUENCE ON SOCIAL MEDIA?
WHERE DO YOU GO TO GET THAT?
>> Dana: I THINK IF YOU LOOK
OVER TIME, HAVING A COLLEGE
DEGREE OVER YOUR LIFETIME AT
THIS POINT SHOWS THAT YOU WOULD
GROW MORE WEALTH IN YOUR LIFE
OVER TIME.
HOWEVER, I THINK THE REASON YOU
SEE THOSE NUMBERS GO DOWN SO
MUCH SINCE 2020 IS LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED IN ACADEMIA.
PARENTS ARE WATCHING THEIR KIDS
COME HOME GOING, WHAT DID YOU
JUST LEARNED?
IT'S FOUR YEARS OF DISNEYLAND.
IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH AND WE ARE
NOT ABLE TO COMPETE WITH THE
REST OF THE WORLD IF WE KEEP UP
THAT PACE.
THERE ARE GREAT WAYS TO STAY
EDUCATED GOING FORWARD.
ESPECIALLY EVEN TODAY, SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS.
YOUTUBE, PODCASTS.
I UNDERSTAND WHY A FAMILY WOULD
WANT THEIR KID TO GO TO COLLEGE
BUT I ALSO UNDERSTAND THE
POLITICAL REALIGNMENT.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF ONE AND
YOU'RE REPUBLICANS GARNER ALL
THE SUPPORT OF THE WORKING CLASS
AND INCREASINGLY MINORITY
POPULATIONS AND ONE OF THE
REASONS IS BECAUSE THEY ARE
SAYING WE ARE GOING TO BE FOR
YOU.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE INCREASINGLY
BECOMING THE PARTY OF THE
COLLEGE EDUCATED.
THE COLLEGE EDUCATED ARE MORE
WEALTHY.
BIDEN IS GOING TO TRY TO TELL US
THAT WE ARE NOT IN A RECESSION.
THAT THE JOBS MARKET IS SO
STRONG THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
BUT THE RELATIVELY RICH STUDENTS
WHO ARE NOW WORKING APPARENTLY
THEY'VE GOT A GREAT JOB MARKET.
THEY CAN'T PAY THEIR
STUDENT LOANS.
IT'S COSTING ALL OF A $6 BILLION
A MONTH IN ORDER TO PAY FOR THE
STUDENT LOAN SERVICING.
ALL OF US ARE GETTING SCREWED
OVER IN THIS DEAL AND THE
PRESIDENT CAN'T JUST MAKE A
DECISION BECAUSE THE LEFT IS
GIVING HIM SUCH A HARD TIME SO
EVERY TWO MONTHS HE HAS TO RE-UP
THE SITUATION.
IT'S A TERRIBLE THING FOR THE
COUNTRY WHERE IT'S REALLY BAD
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
AND ABIGAIL SPANBERGER, BY THE
WAY.
>> Rosanna: I DON'T KNOW WHO
SHE IS BUT SHE SOUNDS GREAT.
AND DELICIOUS.
GERALDO, IS FORGIVENESS EQUAL
VOTES?
WHERE DOES IT END?
AOC WARNED THE PRESIDENT THAT IF
HE DIDN'T FORGIVE SOME OF THE
STUDENT DEBT WITH DOWN THE LINE
WOULD KIND OF ALIENATE YOUNG
DEMOCRATS.
>> Geraldo: WITHOUT BEING
OVERLY WONKY, I THINK FIRST OF
ALL IT'S UNFAIR TO EVERYONE WHO
HAS PAID THEIR STUDENT LOANS OFF
OVER THIS GENERATION.
I THINK THERE'S A QUESTION OF
EQUITY.
ALSO YOU FORGIVE IT NOW, WHAT
ABOUT NEXT YEAR'S STUDENTS IN
THE YEAR AFTER THAT AND THE YEAR
AFTER THAT?
DO YOU KEEP FORGIVING BECAUSE
YOU FORGAVE IT IN 2022?
QUESTIONING WHETHER OR NOT A
COLLEGE EDUCATION IS WORTH IT IS
A REAL ISSUE FOR MANY FAMILIES.
I TOLD THE STORY OF HOW I
BROUGHT THIS CHAIR BACK FROM
AFRICA.
WELDER OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL MAKING
$85,000 A YEAR.
I THINK IF YOU HAVE TO CONSIDER.
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SHOULD BE
VASTLY EXPANDED.
IN TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT THIS
IS A BRIBE, IT'S BRIBE BUT KIDS
WILL REMEMBER, IT WILL BE
REMEMBER I'VE GOT TO PAY BACK.
>> Rosanna: HE IS NOT GOING TO
DECIDE HOW THE OF AUGUST.
>> Geraldo: I THINK COLLEGE IS
OFTEN A SCAM.
THE LAWNS, THE FOUNTAINS, THE
SWIMMING POOLS, THE PARKS.
>> Rosanna: JESSE, IN YOUR
WORLD, DID YOU GET A JOB IN WHAT
YOU MAJORED IN?
>> Jesse: I'M NOT A HISTORY
PROFESSOR, SO NO.
I AM PRO-COLLEGE, IF THAT'S
CONTROVERSIAL OPINION, I REALLY
DON'T CARE.
I FEEL BAD FOR JILL BIDEN.
COULD YOU IMAGINE BEING MARRIED
TO JOE?
THE GUY CAN'T MAKE A DECISION.
HE HAS BEEN MULLING THIS HIS
ENTIRE PRESIDENCY.
>> Rosanna: WE HAVE A
DEADLINE, DON'T WE?
THE END OF AUGUST.
>> Jesse: EVERY MONTH WE DO
THE SAME STORY.
JOE BIDEN IS CONSIDERING.
DO IT ALREADY.
DID YOU MAKE A DINNER
RESERVATION?
STILL MULLING IT.
>> IF YOU WANT TO TALK
INFLATION.
IT USED TO COST $150,000 FOR A
FOUR-YEAR EDUCATION.
IT COSTS NOW $300,000.
A DEGREE CAN'T COST MORE THAN A
HOME.
HE'S ALWAYS STRUGGLING ALL THESE
BIG NEEDS.
BIG OIL.
LOWER YOUR PRICES.
WHEN YOU GET THE UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS TOGETHER AND SAY DOES
THE MIDDLEBURY SKI TEAM NEED A
SEPARATE WEIGHT ROOM FOR THE
TRANSGENDER STUDENTS?
NO.
THEY DON'T.
THEY HAVE $1.5 BILLION ENDOWMENT
AT MIDDLE BARRY.
ARE YOU SAYING THAT YOU KEEP
RAISING TUITION?
>> Rosanna: WHAT IS $10,000
AMONG FRIENDS?
HAVE YOU HEARD WHAT COLLEGE
TUITION IS, $10,000 IS A DROP IN
THE BUCKET.
>> Greg: WHY SEND YOUR KIDS TO
COLLEGE, YOUR LOVING KIDS TO
COLLEGE WHEN THEY RETURN TURNING
AGAINST YOU AND BIOLOGY.
YOU ARE RUINING BRAINS.
GERALDO'S POINT, ALL THE PEOPLE
WHO PAID OFF THEIR STUDENT LOANS
AND THEY PROBABLY WORKED NIGHTS
TO DO IT, THIS IS A SLAP IN
THEIR FACE.
IT'S LIKE BEING AT A RESTAURANT
AND ORDERING YOUR DESSERT AND
THEN EATING IT AND PAYING FOR IT
AND THEN SUDDENLY THEY ANNOUNCED
THAT THERE IS A PIE EATING
CONTEST.
>> Jesse: I HATE WHEN THAT
HAPPENS.
>> Greg: YOU ARE GETTING
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS TO PAY FOR A
GIFT THAT BENEFITS DEMOCRATS WHO
DON'T NEED IT.
THIS ISN'T LIKE WELL FOR --
WELFARE.
GIVEN TO WHITE HISTORY MAJORS
WHO CAN SPEND THAT MONEY THEY
WOULD'VE SPENT ON THE LOAN ON
HOLIDAYS IN THE HAMPTONS.
MY SOLUTION IS IF YOU WANT TO
FORGIVE THAT STUPID DEBT, TAKE
IT FROM THE COLLEGES SINCE THEY
HAVE TRIPLED THE TUITION THE
LAST 30 YEARS AND THEIR
EDUCATION SUCKS.
DO NOT TAKE IT WITH US BECAUSE I
SWEAR TO GOD YOU WILL SEE A REAL
INSURRECTION.
YOU ARE STEALING MONEY.
YOU ARE STEALING MONEY FROM
PEOPLE AND GIVING IT TO PEOPLE.
THIS IS REDISTRIBUTION BUT IT'S
NOT EVEN GOING TO THE POOR.
HE'S ACTUALLY TAKING MONEY FROM
PEOPLE TO BRIBE PEOPLE TO VOTE
FOR HIM.
THIS IS MORAL.
IT'S THE WORST THING.
>> Jesse: I'VE NEVER SEEN HE
WAS UPSET.
>> Greg: EVERY TIME I THINK
ABOUT THIS IT MAKES ME SO ANGRY.
IT'S ACTUAL THEFT.
THEY THINK THEY CAN GET AWAY
WITH IT BY SAYING IT'S ONLY TEN
RAN HERE.
IT'S ONLY THIS.
STUDENTS CAN AFFORD IT.
THEY CAN AFFORD IT.
IF YOU CAN AFFORD A CAR PAYMENT,
YOU CAN AFFORD YOUR COLLEGE
PAYMENT.
IT IS ROUGHLY THE SAME.
250, 270.